so uh i'm in a villa
i'm i'm a hostage and uh this villa has
been converted into a jail all the
windows are borrowed shut i can't open
any window
for three years the world has heard
nothing
from princess latifah the missing
daughter
of one of the world's richest men
dubai's billionaire ruler
mohammed bin rashid al maktoum but now
you can hear princess latifah's story in
her own words
i'm doing this video from a bathroom
because
it's the only room with the door i can
lock
in these video messages princess latifah
says she is being held against her will
in a royal villa in dubai and
the door to my room i put um
because i can't lock the door to my room
there's no key i put
like a bottle and some boxes underneath
so if somebody opens the handle it will
make a large
loud sound so it will be like an alarm
so i stopped talking
nine months ago my secret communication
with the princess stopped
we don't know why or where she is now
latifah's father is the ruler of dubai
and the prime minister
of the united arab emirates the sheikh
is a powerful and influential man
with horse racing and property assets in
the uk
he's regularly seen alongside heads of
state
including the queen but there's another
side
allegations that have come from a number
of members of his family
two ex-wives claim he abused them
as have latifah and one of her sisters
the sheikh denies all of this
from the outside sheikha latifah
appeared to live a life of luxury
she had her horses a love of animals a
passion for skydiving
but replying to questions sky news sent
to her in the spring and summer of 2019
she tells of a different reality i'm
being punished
and i don't know what can happen to me
and how long this will last and
if they decide to release me like how my
life will be
but i'm not safe at all this story
starts back in 2018 when latifa
first went public in a youtube post and
i'm making this video
because it could be the last video i
make
yeah she says she was desperate for her
freedom
so that year in february she tried to
escape
her best friend tina yao heinen went
with her
i believe that latifa
has wanted to be free all her life
and i'm not satisfied until latifa is
allowed to travel to a country of her
choice
and and get the freedom that she's
always wanted
they made plans and practiced with
latifah trying different techniques
to navigate water in the palace pool
then with the plans in place they drove
from downtown dubai
across the border into oman
from muscat they took a small boat then
jet skis
to a waiting yacht and they set sail
for goa but just miles from the coast of
india
and what they believed was safety armed
indian commandos boarded
you know i was i was prepared for
anything you know i'm used to much worse
and i'm prepared for anything i
was prepared to even lose my life for
freedom
but i wasn't prepared to put my best
friend in that situation
or to see her get hurt that was the
hardest thing
latifah and those helping her were
forcibly taken back to the united arab
emirates
i was holding on to the yacht like with
my hands the side of
the ropes on the side of the yacht i was
holding onto it and they were pulling me
off
i was fighting as hard as i could i was
wearing flip-flops and my flip-flops
came
off so i was barefoot i didn't have any
weapons i was tired
i was up against a lot of people with
weapons you know like it wasn't easy
in these clips recorded on a smartphone
that was smuggled to her shaykh latifah
says she was beaten and injected with a
substance she believes was a
tranquilizer
the one who was sitting in my stomach he
grabs my chest and he says to me shut up
shut up
so i got really really angry and i was
hitting him with my hands and screaming
at him to get off me
and i was like so so angry and i just
kept
fighting with him really really hard and
nobody cared but then eventually because
like i was really really really like
struggling a lot
the other emirati guy told him uh like
get offer and then he sat on me and he
was trying to help the other guy tie up
my legs but i was fighting
and this guy came with a small
um pouch like a camouflage pouch and
he took out the needle and he injected
me in my arm and i was like
fighting i was saying don't do that
don't do that don't do that when i woke
up the private jet had already landed in
dubai
and one of the policewoman she was like
i woke up and
she was braiding my hair while i was
asleep
and i noticed that my hands were like
really bruised and swollen especially in
my left hand
because the zip ties were still on me
and i was still on the stretcher still
tied completely to the stretcher she
says she was questioned and taken to a
cell
in al aware jail on the outskirts of
dubai before she was moved to the
guarded villa
the cell was in section 13 in alhawi
jail
and i was there from my kidnap
day until may 27 2018
so approximately three months i was in
in a jail cell for quite some time i was
sleep deprived and
i wouldn't really sleep properly i would
just sometimes pass out from exhaustion
it wasn't um it wasn't a good situation
and yeah the bathroom had no door and i
think it's just another way like to
humiliate you you know
this is very much latifah's account her
father has a very different view
he says latifa was tricked into escaping
by criminals
who wanted money and that returning her
to dubai
was a rescue mission pictures were
released
nine months after the escape showing the
princess with former un human rights
chief
mary robinson who says she was duped
into taking part in the photos
the shake says the princess is safe and
well
and that they want to maintain her
privacy so
which version should we believe many of
the details from latifah's account
have been accepted by a senior british
judge
now a british judge has found that the
ruler of dubai is responsible for the
kidnapping and detention of two of his
daughters
latifah's story was brought up during a
high court case between the sheikh
and his now former wife princess hayer
bent al-hussein
in that case the judge accepted that the
sheikh had been responsible for the
forcible kidnapping and detention of
latifa
the judge accepted the actions were
undertaken upon the instructions
of the father and carried out by agents
acting on his behalf
he accepted eyewitness testimony from
princess hayer
who told the court latifah was held
against her will
she was locked in a house guarded from
the outside
and from the inside in response to the
court case
the sheikh said as a head of government
i was not able to participate in the
court's fact-finding process
this has resulted in the release of a
fast-finding judgment
which inevitably tells only one side of
the story
her friends did not hear from latifah
after the escape
until around a year later a message
reached tina
who had been on the boat with the
princess when i got the first message
from latifah i was i couldn't believe it
was happening
i was so emotional i i couldn't sleep
for a couple of nights
um because there was this time frame
that i was having a hard time contacting
her
it's it's very hard to imagine how it
must be like
to be in prison for for three years
already
another friend david hague who was also
charged and detained in the uae
over fraud allegations says he is hoping
the videos will encourage
the un and others to act we want
politicians and
former politicians and world leaders and
you know celebrities and so-called
influence all the people that go to
dubai
in the uae promote that country to wake
up and see what the reality is this is a
country that is
literally i mean people will be on those
beaches in dubai a few hundred meters
away from where latifah
is essentially in solitary confinement a
hostage
we agreed to run these videos when
latifa herself
wanted them to be made public but we
have not heard from her
for nine months her video messages
have now been passed by her friends to
the united nations
so we have made the decision to air them
as for where latifa is now that
is unknown representatives of the sheikh
did not respond to requests for comment